Hello.
Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live. I
am your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
TimescaleDB,
a time series database that is a little
bit different from what we may be accustomed
to. Timescale is a relational time series database,
which brings with it a lot of flexibility,
value, and power that we're gonna take a
look at today.
No. I'm not gonna do this alone. I
am gonna be guided. And for that, I
am joined by Aftar Serrafan from TimescaleDB.
Hi there. How are you? Hi, David. Thanks
for having me on the stream. It's a
pleasure to be here.
The the pleasure is all mine. I'm really
looking forward to to playing with Timescale
and just showing how interesting and cool Timescale
is in general, but even how cool are
some of the databases are that we're getting
coming out nowadays as well. So
would you like to take a few moments
just now to kind of introduce yourself, tell
us a little bit about you, and then
we'll talk about Timescale itself.
Fantastic.
Well, hi, everyone. I'm
basically
streaming in today from New York City.
I'm Afthar. I'm a developer advocate here at
Timescale,
and I'm originally from South Africa, but now
live in New York City. I'm super interested
in using technology to empower people. That's really
why I enjoy
being a developer advocate here at Timescale. You
get to learn new things all the time
and explore a bunch of different
use cases and and different projects, some of
which we're gonna get into in the stream
today.
And as I mentioned, you know, part of
my job is learning new stuff all the
time. So you can, follow me on Twitter
or my personal website is offthora.com
if you'd like to learn more. But yeah,
excited to get into TimescaleDB
today with you, David.
Awesome. Very, very cool.
Alright. I believe we're gonna
skip the chat around what it is and
you're gonna walk us through some slides that
you're prepared just to kinda give us a
little bit of a overview and some flavor
on what Timescale DB is. So let me
pop those up onto our screen.
Please take it away.
Fantastic.
So I just wanna give a a short
intro to what is TimescaleDB,
keeping in mind that, you know, some people
may be familiar with time series databases in
general,
whereas other people that might actually be a
foreign concept. So let's just take an overview
of of what exactly is TimescaleDB.
The simplest way to think of Timescale
is that it's Postgres with time series superpowers.
A lot of our users describe Timescale as
times Postgres for time series.
And there's really
what what that really means is that Timescale
is a relational database
packaged as a a relational time series database
packaged as a Postgres extension.
And this is in contrast to a lot
of other time series databases out there, which
are traditionally no SQL. So for example,
influx DB, which is something that David has
worked with before and knows very well.
And some other databases that are used for
time series data, things like MongoDB
and Cassandra.
So
there's sort of six main things that I
wanted to introduce you to around Timescale.
So the first one is that, you know,
Timescale is
built on top of Postgres. And so that
means
the same Postgres that people might be familiar
with from just storing relational data,
it all the same features are available
and Timescale basically runs on top of that.
You inherit the whole Postgres ecosystem
with all of its reliability and tooling and
and
and community that it's built over the past
twenty to thirty years or so.
The other thing to keep in mind with
Timescale is a lot most the reasons why
people gravitate towards it is because Timeseries data
requires
performance
that,
traditional databases can't really give. You know, when
you're dealing with Timeseries data, it's a lot
of data coming in,
constantly from,
the devices that you're monitoring
or whether it's some sort of deployment.
There's a like a DevOps use case as
well. So you wanna pick a database that
can actually give you the kind of performance
both in ingest and querying.
And so Timescale is is a really good
one to use for that. And the other
reason is, you know, once you reach a
certain scale,
that's kinda why Timescale has a scale in
the name. Once you reach once you reach
a certain scale,
you're gonna require a database that can actually
keep up with, in in our case, supporting
terabytes or petabytes of data.
And then the last three points is just,
you know, it's it's actually easier to have
this relational and time series data together.
And we also have advanced time series features,
some of which we're gonna get into things
like compression
and continuous aggregates
and automated data retention policies so that it's
not just about performance, but it's about just
working with time series data in general.
Some other things I wanted to mention, you
know, those
people who are unfamiliar with time series databases,
a good way to think about it is
that, you know, time series data is data
that show that that represents how things change
over time. So four examples of this that
I just wanted to introduce to you is
the first one is of DevOps monitoring.
So for example, I just have a SQL
query on the screen here that shows the
change of memory consumption for containers in a
Kubernetes cluster over the past ten minutes. So
that's an example of something that you'd wanna
wanna monitor with Timescale. Some other examples are
things like application metrics. You know, you're looking
at,
you know, user behavior on a website or
in an app each time
a user performs some sort of event, that
event stream is is time series data. And
another example is the Internet of Things. We're
gonna take a look at two demos later
on.
Any devices that you that you may use,
for example, smart devices, anyone who has an
Alexa or a Google Home or something like
that. And then traditionally, the traditional example of
time series data is financial data, stock prices.
Those of you who are
familiar with, you know, GameStop and and stuff
like that, all that stuff that's been happening
recently
will realize that, you know, as the prices
go up and down, that's time series data
for for finance.
Okay. And then I have some slides here
about, like, what makes Timescale a bit different,
but maybe we can save that for later
on or I just wanna give you a
chance to jump in here before I just,
you know, carry on. But our this is
about Timescale's
major abstraction called the hyper table, but maybe
we can deal with this later on in
the stream.
Yeah. Whatever you think is best for for
people to be aware of just now before
we start kicking the tires on this. So,
you know, if you wanna cover it, please
feel free. Otherwise, we can come back to
it later.
Okay. Well, it might just be two minutes.
I think that the reason why I'm bringing
this up is, you know, a lot of
people,
it can be difficult to understand, you know,
how can a relational database scale for time
series data.
And so that's why I want to introduce
the major abstraction of TimescaleDB,
which is this thing that we call a
hyper table. So, you know, one of the
benefits of using Timescale is that it allows
you to ingest these get really high ingestion
rates
on your data. So in this case, millions
of data points a second. And the way
that we do that is to do this
abstraction called a hyper table,
which is you can kind of think of
so so this is how the the hyper
table works.
So what Timescale has is
automatic partitioning in both space and time. So
if you think of
your traditional
relational table,
what we do is we have
these different subtables,
which we call chunks. So in this case,
you know, you have data coming in in
time, but you also might have different kinds
of data maybe from different devices or different
locations or something like that. And so what
we have is each chunk represents
both at a point in time as well
as you can also partition in space, which
is, you know, the the the type or
the location. And so these chunks are kinda
like subtables.
And so what happens is that the these
because you're dealing with these subtables underneath and
not just one large table,
the time that it takes to actually query
data and ingest data is
shortened
quite a bit. It's it's sped up quite
a bit. But as a user,
you're still dealing with just one
abstraction of a of a single table when
in reality,
as you can see, there's actually,
in some cases, hundreds
or,
you know, even more of these subtables underneath.
So that's like the main abstraction. And I
think what that allows you to do is
to make what's called wide and shallow queries
as well as narrow and deep queries. So
wide and shallow queries, can think about, you
know, you wanna understand what is the state
of all my devices in the past five
minutes. So here, you just wanna look at
this
latest
time period and you can see like, okay,
it's these three chunks right here. But if
you wanted to do what's called a deep
and narrow query, which is like, you know,
for a sudden location,
show me the history going back one year
or two years, that's just for example, if
I'm just looking at the blue
location,
then that's gonna be this middle row right
here. So you can see you can that's
kind of to give you an intuition about
why you get this kind of performance gains
when you do use TimescaleDB.
Then I have some slides here about, like,
developer productivity. It's basically the showing the fact
that, you know, a lot of people are
can be confused that, you know, time series
timescale is built upon Postgres.
So what does that mean? It basically means
that, you know, for all your relational queries,
it uses the Postgres query planner. And then
for time series queries and stuff that use
TimescaleDB special functions,
we have modified the query plan in such
a way that it then uses TimescaleDB for
those things. So all the reliability
and all the
kind of backup and tooling that you associate
with Postgres, all that stuff still works. The
only thing that we modified
is how you deal with time series related
queries and and functions.
And And as a result of being built
on Postgres, it basically means that everything that
you're used to in the Postgres ecosystem,
whether it's visualization or ingestion tools and stuff
like that, that all that still works. You
know, whatever works with Postgres works with Timescale.
And so all these things, I'm gonna do
a demo later on using Grafana
as an example
of a visualization tool. But, you know, all
the things that you're used to ingesting and
visualizing data with, those all work with TimescaleDB.
And this is just a last thing to
give you an idea of the amount of
people who are using it today. You know,
sometimes it's when you have a new software
that you're evaluating, it's good to get a
sense of, like, where else is it used
in production. So we have over a million
active databases right now and used at places
like AppDynamics,
Cisco,
Samsung,
IBM, all those all those places. So but
that's just just an overview for you to
get a taste of Timescale. I know we're
gonna get stuck in in just a moment
into the actual code of it.
Nice. Awesome.
I think I would just I I think
I've got two points now. Right? Got it.
One one
is,
you know, I love it when I see
examples of, you know, this is the the
type of time series, you know. And that's
great because we show people something that is
applicable within their context, whether they're from financial
background or software engineering or, you know, SRE,
etcetera. Yeah. But what I always love is
just that there's not a single second of
this any given day that anybody on this
planet isn't surrounded by time series data. Literally,
everything in Everything. Humidity,
temperature, rainfall, precipitation.
All of this stuff could be tracked and
monitored in time series database. Even, you know,
exchange rates when you buy a cup of
coffee. So I I love Timescale data. And
I'm really really looking forward to playing with
us today.
And also, a second thing I wanted to
mention is that, you know, I do have
a lot of experience in Timescale,
you know, formally working in the Prometheus community
and then moving to influx.
And one of the biggest points of frustration
or questions I always would always get is
why can't I just use query languages I'm
familiar with?
And this is one of the biggest selling
points I feel for for Timescale is that
it's built on a backbone of an open
source database that many,
many people are familiar with using query languages
and tools that many, many people are familiar
with. So I'm very excited, and I think
we should just start playing with Timescale.
Let's let's get stuck in. Yeah. That sounds
good to me. Alright.
So let's see. Let's get my machine's screen
shared.
Alright.
So here I have the Timescale
website.
Typically, what we'll do is we'll just click
on the docs. We'll find some sort of
getting started guide. There's always a getting started
guide
and try and just cut through some of
the basics that people need
to make and start their own Timescale journey.
So
I think the first thing we really need
to do is to install Timescale. Now
what's your recommendation here? Do we go with
a docker, a container image? Has there brew
packages?
What what would you do?
Yeah. So there's a couple ways to get
started. I think depending on on what you're
most familiar with, Docker
is is usually good.
The one that we recommend to people, obviously,
because it's the easiest to get started is
using Timescale
Cloud or Timescale Forge which is a hosted
option.
You know, there is a a free trial
that you get $300 in credits. So, you
know, if you just wanna check it out
or if you're just using it for a
small project
and don't wanna actually pay
to to upkeep it, you know, if you're
if you're not running in production or or
seriously or if you're just kicking the tires,
then that's that's also another option as well.
Well, I do love to I do love
showing off cloud products when they're available. Do
I need to enter a credit card detail
or will it No. So yeah. Actually, I'd
recommend choosing the Timescale Forge. So let me
actually explain a little bit about why there's
two options there.
It's funny because when people
usually
kind of sign up for Timescale,
it's just through the the front page of
the website and and the docs kinda need
to get updated a little bit. That's showing
that, you know, we're a bit behind on
on updating ourselves. But basically, difference between Timescale
Cloud and Timescale Forge is that Forge is
a newer product that
we're building that is gonna have much more
deep integration with things like you mentioned Prometheus
before
as well as just a more rich experience
for users. It's a it's a bit of
a younger product. Whereas Timescale Cloud is
a product that's been around for almost two
years now and that just has more regions
and
more configurations for folks who want more flexibility,
whereas forge is just, you know, instances based
in The US.
So that's the that's the the difference there.
Alright. So let's try
forge.
Where else is it?
Oh, well, we'll go with it.
And I'm not these
things.
K.
Let me just pop that open over here.
Copy link.
Oh,
so I have Timescale now. Right?
Okay.
So the page that you're seeing now is
just the the direct page to create a
database.
So
you can just go ahead and and enter
a name and select a configuration from there.
Alright. So we can just say this is
Rawkode Live.
I mean, I'm assuming for what we're gonna
be playing with today is the smallest instances.
It's probably okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That should be fine.
gig of data. I'm sure that will be
cool.
Sure. I'll save that over there.
That's me now showing the world two passwords,
but
I will remove this current and change the
password afterwards. Yeah.
Alright. So
what we get now is just our pretty
standard postgres connection line. Does does that just
to clarify. Right? Does that mean I can
use
any postgres compatible
GUI locally?
Yeah. So I actually use p g admin.
Later on, I'll show you my p g
admin screen. But, yeah, you could use whatever
you want that connects with Postgres to interact
with Timescale,
whether it's good old p s equal, which
is the the terminal based
UI for
Postgres
or stuff like p g admin, d beaver,
you know, whatever whatever takes your fancy. So,
you know, you get to choose what tools
you wanna use, and it's gonna be compatible.
Excellent.
Definitely a major one. Now what about this
multi node connection info? Is Timescale
horizontally
scalable?
Yeah. So in the in the most recent
release
of Timescale
Timescale two point o, we've introduced
horizontal scalability or multi node capabilities.
You know, one of the original criticisms of
Timescale when it first released was that, you
know, it really scales well on one node.
But what happens when you wanna get into
really large scale production deployments
where you have, you know, these
20 node clusters dealing with,
you know, billions of data points every every
minute or so.
And so that's that's what we've just actually
introduced that. So that's a new feature on
Timescale Forge.
And,
yeah, if you need that, I think there's
one or two tutorials on YouTube that takes
you through exactly, you know, like, how the
multi node connection info is different from the
general connection info.
But for the sake of simplicity and not
confusing folks at home, I'll point you to
that to to learn more. But That's just
the information that you'll need to get the
multi node set up up and running.
Okay. Awesome.
So
I guess we should go back to we've
we've got our instance. We had that little
pop up that says it's running. So now
we can go back to again, Startup Guide
and
I'd recommend
the one that might be good to do
is under tutorials. It's getting started hello timescale
because
this current getting started guide
kinda explains the stuff that I've been telling
you that I explained in the slides already
where it's kinda like the abstraction of hyper
tables and what is TimescaleDB,
whereas this one is actually a really nice
tutorial. I worked on this myself
about using a real world dataset and analyzing
it using TimescaleDB.
In this case, it's about taxis in New
York City and
analyzing their
ride behavior and and stuff like that. So
it's actually quite fun.
Okay. Let's do the NYC data then. So
do I have to download this file?
Yeah. So the first step is just to
download the dataset.
Alright.
Sure. That won't take too long.
Yeah. Ten seconds. Okay. Cool.
So let's see.
Prerequisites,
this tutorial.
Yeah.
Okay. I probably know enough SQL to be
dangerous, and I'm sure you'll keep me right
as we go. So Yeah. Yeah. It the
SQL is actually spelled out quite
what is it? In in detail in the
tutorial. So even if you're a beginner, you'll
still be able to understand, you know, what's
going on.
Okay. So
how does this want me to interact with
the cluster? Do I need to install a
post course client?
So
what you can do is
you can use
p SQL, which I think is installed
by default on a on a Mac. But,
yeah, basically, you'll need some sort of post
course client in order to complete this. So
whatever you'd you'd like.
Right.
Computers are no on that one. So Oh,
no. Okay. Let's
just pull up the brew page.
See if it's got a client on its
own.
Oh, it should install.
Postgres. Yeah. So it should come with that.
Maybe just update.
And what was the name of the GUI
you also recommended there? Another one that I
like is called PG admin.
It's kind of the more old school
database administrators
one.
I'm not sure if there's a proof for
that, but
Yep. P g admin four and also install
Postgres.
And I think that gives us a better
that gives us a few options with how
we wanna work with it. So I'm gonna
Exactly. See both. Yeah. So,
hopefully, this is pretty
quick.
Is p g admin the web one or
is that an actual
Mac app?
So it's a it's a browser based one,
kinda like,
you know, if you've you've you've used Grafana
and stuff before, it just opens up a
web browser
or web page in your browser, and that's
how you interact with it. Yeah. I can
I always remember p g you know, PHP
my admin from back in my PHP days?
That was Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Back I've developed
a couple of websites using that very rudimentary
stuff when I was still learning, like, web
development a few
maybe six years ago or so. Yeah.
Alright. So I'm sure this will be very
quick. So why don't we pop over here
just now? Yeah. So the first thing I
want us to do is just Go ahead.
Oh, yeah. Feel free to interrupt me. Was
just about to say there's one for
folks who are seeing this and, you know,
who who have no idea about how to
use P SQL,
which is one of the things that you
might use later on. There's actually a tutorial
in the docs about how to install and
use P SQL. So that's, know, if you're
a total beginner or just
wanna wanna refresh the basics, that's there as
well.
I think if you just search p SQL
on the docs, you should should find it.
But that's there to reference.
Here we go. Yeah.
Hey.
So this looks like we've still got a
minute to go. So you say PCQL,
I say SQL.
I guess people will be wondering what the
difference there is.
And that's the I think the short answer
is this technology. We all pronounce things differently,
and that's okay.
Exactly.
Not one for these dogmatic wars and correct
pronunciation
of technical terms.
I think it's silly.
Okay. So we're gonna create a database
called NYC data.
And so this is how we interact with
Timescale.
We have to enable
an extension.
Yeah. So because you're using
Timescale's like hosted instance, that's actually been already
done and it's been enabled by default.
But for folks who are using like Docker
or just installing on bare metal
on your on your computer,
you just have to enable that extension. That's
the create extension.
What is it? That
command,
and that'll that'll enable TimescaleDB
on on on your Postgres instance.
So that just just so I understand how
this works then. Like, if I don't enable
that extension, I'm I'm really just working with
the native Postgres and its query planner and
such. But on a database level, I can
enable that extension,
which brings in the custom query planner and
the custom storage layer. Is that right? Exactly.
% correct.
Cool. That'll be the only time you see
that today. Everything else, I'm gonna get completely
wrong. But
alright. We now have those things installed. So,
yep, we have PSQL
and let's see. The admin
is running on a port.
Who
knows?
It's been a while since I've installed all
of this. I forgot how much trouble it
can be.
Alright. I'm just gonna use this because I'm
I think I'll be able to pull enough
of this back out of my head to
make it work. So let's see if we
can connect. Right? So here is our line.
I'm sure it's the s h.
Well, this has got credentials on it too.
Right? Yeah. You what you will need to
do is
after the TSTP admin,
you will need to put in your password.
So it'll be a colon followed by your
password,
or you can I think if you do
this, then it might prompt you for your
password afterwards,
which you can enter it? So that might
be the safer way.
Yeah.
Okay. So
let's not make it up. Let's do that.
I won't make it up. We'll do that
myself. So h s host.
But we actually have more than a host.
We have a full
connection string.
Yeah. Yeah. So Let me just double check
how to
how to actually connect.
Alright. So I don't see end of an
obvious there. So I'm also gonna take a
look at p g admin four and see
what the port number is there.
That may just be running there in the
background quite happy.
So if I were gonna deploy and install
oh, no.
Mac.
Nope.
Container.
Let's see what port it runs on. So
I think if you remove the
the
dash h
there and just put the
it's the the service URI afterwards,
it should work and take out the
that send me the quotes at the end
of it there.
I didn't like that. That's what I just
tried.
Oh, I didn't?
I think it would need to yeah. Okay.
We need to close because of, you know,
the Oh, because of the string. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. Alright. So now I need my password,
which I kept over here.
And then there we go. Success. Okay. And
then if you just do a backslash d
x,
that will show you that TimescaleDB
is actually installed
on this Postgres
on your Postgres instance, on your TimescaleDB instance.
And, you know, you can actually verify that,
you know, you're you're good to go from
here.
Okay. Is that just shorthand for show databases?
So x is the extensions.
Showing your databases will be
I think it's
now you're testing my PC called knowledge.
Let me double check.
Let's consult Google.
Yeah. I have no idea. It's been too
long for me.
Okay.
I think show databases is with my influx
command. Yeah. It'll just be backslash l,
like list. Yeah. So then you should see
a databases.
Postgres is the database by default.
If you want to oh, I'm sorry. So
Postgres is the default database, and then the
the database that you'll interact with is called
TSDB.
The last one at the bottom,
which is TimescaleDB.
To do that, to choose
TimescaleDB,
you do backslash c,
which means choose
and then TSDB.
I'm just making up commands. It's all good.
You might as well try try try what
you know. Most of the time, it actually
works. So yeah. Yeah. I wonder if that's
just MariaDB slash MySQL,
the show and use syntax. Maybe it is
okay. Yeah. So now we are using our
TSDB.
So we wanna be able to
will there be any tables
that are created or is that something we
know we're gonna do? So that's something we're
gonna do in in step one here. So
if you just go back to the
tutorial.
So this actually create database thing. Since we
already have a database and we've enabled Timescale,
we can actually skip that step and
just move move right ahead.
Alright. So we have our SQL file
and well, yeah. I'm assuming there's a CSV
on it too. I've not extracted it yet.
So why don't we do that?
And notes.
Okay.
We've already got our connection working. Oh, the
command was right there in front of us.
I just wasn't going through the
It's okay. It's it's good to be impatient
sometimes. But, yeah, that's the that's the command
that we figured out.
Alright. We've done that. It's then we did
the d x command. So we've seen the
extensions,
and now
we're gonna need three tables. So we're gonna
have a hyper table, which we've already spoken
about in the slides.
If anyone has any questions and you're watching,
please feel free to drop them in the
comment section. We will tackle as many of
them as we can as we go.
We're also gonna have a regular post gross
tables. Again, this is one of the superpowers
of Timescale is that we have the choice
to work with relational data and time series
data.
And that's gonna store payment types. So we're
using that as like a I guess, like
a metadata store and then another
regular postgres table called rates.
Okay. And I'm assuming that's just for some
sort of calculations.
Yeah. We're gonna we're gonna be using all
the tables later on.
But, yeah, basically, the the the the hyper
table is gonna be storing the time series
data. So every time a ride takes place,
it'll store the time of the that that
ride took place, so the start time and
the end time.
And then
all sorts of information about the ride,
which will then be associated
with
the other relational tables. So you have, like,
rates and I think there's, like, ride types
or something like that where those are just
IDs to
stuff in the relational table. So that's it's
yeah. As you mentioned, just metadata and and
descriptions in the relational tables.
Okay. So this seems to create,
I guess, as rates just a regular table
and then a hyper table is a I
don't wanna say view because I think that
word is overloaded in this context, but maybe
you could try explain what this create hyper
table is is doing.
Yeah. So basically, the way you create a
hyper table is that you first just create
a
relational
table with all the with the schema that
you want. So in this case, we have
all the things like let me actually just
open this up here. So we have all
the things like
the the pickup date time and passenger count
and all that kind of stuff. And then
what you do afterwards
is
run the create hyper table command, which actually
will convert
your
regular postgres table to a hyper table. And
then you can
perform all sorts of functions reserved
to be performed on the hyper tables on
that. So there's some advanced functions like
data retention policies,
down sampling, and things that can only be
performed on hyper tables. And so that's just
to distinguish which tables are regular tables and
which tables are actually hyper tables.
And is there any default,
you know, time to live or data exploration
policy when you create the hyper table or
is it all infinite?
So yeah. Everything is infinite.
Yeah. There's no
time to live and there's no data exploration
policy. Those are things that you can actually
set up
on a on a per hyper table basis
or
there's actually
a way that you can set up a
custom retention policy for all your hyper tables,
but that's only if you if you'd like
to. And for those people who are interested
in that, the timescale feature related to that
is called
user defined actions.
And
the the actual stuff to do with data
retention is under the automated retention policies.
So, you know, for folks at home wanna
check that out, you can.
Cool. Alright. So we've created those.
Now we're just gonna create a couple more.
So this is just our yeah. The metadata
payment types and sort of
SQL enum and then our rates.
So let's copy this.
And now we can run
slash d t, which is I'm assuming just
described tables.
Yeah.
And we can see those three tables that
we have already created. So far, it's still
good. Okay.
Now we
wanna copy data from my downloads folder
into this instance.
That's a neat command if it works. Okay.
Now
is that going to be
from where my client was executed,
or
is this gonna expect something that's living on
the cloud server?
Should we just test it and see? Yeah.
Let's test it and see.
Okay. Let's
try copy from
downloads.
I have no idea.
And did that go into a directory? No?
Okay.
Looks good. Yeah. Okay. So that's
from wherever I executed my client. I've just
passed on an absolute path, so we should
be good.
Let's see. There it is. I have a
I have a hunch that it might not
be working, but let me actually try and
figure that out.
Would you expect some sort of output to
suggest that it was copying?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think you might have
to just create a new tab
in your terminal.
And then
Mhmm.
I'm just consulting
the docs to make sure that I'm gonna
say the right thing.
Yeah. I feel like it's doing something. Surely,
would
crash.
We can confirm the hypothesis. Right? Let me
control c.
Could have done a wrong file name first
to see what happens.
I've anger it now.
Alright.
Let's try.
K. And I'll never find it.
Okay. There is our command.
We put the bash x back on. Yeah.
That's for my password.
So now I've got an active session,
and I'm gonna copy this copy command again.
Get the filename wrong.
Yeah. I think that is working because when
the filename's wrong
Okay. Cool.
I think
just maybe this is gonna finish first because
I tried to control c it. It's not
control c ing, so it's probably gonna wait
till
Okay. It finished sendings. Guess
how big was the fail?
Oh,
that's that's all. T crap.
NYC.
One
Point Seven gig.
It can it can take a few minutes.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So
oh, there's a fast alternative.
Yeah. So there's a fast alternative. It's a
little bit more
involved,
but maybe we can try that. Basically, we've
created this
Go program,
you know, for folks who have more higher
ingest rate requirements.
It just takes advantage of parallelism,
And so it just it's a multithreaded way
to insert into your Timescale
database.
Okay.
Well, why don't we
open?
Would that mean if okay. What was the
command? Was it slash d t s t
b?
Nope.
Slash c would be yeah. T s t
b. Alright.
Select
current.
Like, I wonder if there's any data
in this table now from
NYC.
Was it no. Was it just rides? It'll
just be rides. Yeah.
Oh, no.
So we'll have to wait and wait for
that operation to finish. Let me double check
to
ensure that that's working.
Yeah. As I mentioned, I haven't done this
in a while, so it's good to know
where the friction points are.
I personally actually use p
g admin all the time or
have something that's inserting data, like, from a
Python
script or something like that.
But this is
hopefully, will be done soon.
Yeah. I'm not really sure. I wonder if
it's a special command I can send
to postgres to print the status.
Yeah. If you wanna try
if you wanna try using p g admin
as well, that one has a bit of
a better UI to show you, like, the
progress of the insert.
And you just kinda
drag and drop which file you wanna set
inside, and then it'll do it for you.
But you know what port that runs on?
I'm not sure.
It's
just
five. I know that's a postcard port.
Six Oh, it'll be six five
two eight eight, maybe. Try that. I found
this slightly different number. What you're saying? 65288?
Yeah.
Nothing. Okay.
Maybe that's just for my my particular installation.
Yeah. We got a suggestion from.
It's like, Suggest I check my network IO.
Thanks, Vignesh.
I'm pretty sure it
quite fast. I don't even know how to
do that on my Mac.
However
let's
see.
Let's find out how to run this PT
admin thing. So
all through through.
My Google Foo is failing me this evening.
So I did find another command
which suggests
I may try and run that locally
and get a time from it. So let
me show you this. So
because of Stack Overflow,
someone shared
this command
where it seems I can just
type the files through PV. I'm not sure
what that is.
It doesn't appear I have PV.
Good postgres.
We could drop in our string there.
Would that work?
Or am I just being really impatient and
we should just wait? There we go.
Well, I think it actually faintly canceled, didn't
it? Oh, wow. Okay.
It'll be from Rides?
Of course. Yeah.
Rites.
Do you think I should run a local
one?
Let me just double check something.
Yeah.
I think the the hack around this will
definitely be PG admin. So
if we can find a way to open
that,
that'll probably be the best thing.
Yeah. Sure. Alright. Let's see if it's running.
Yeah. I actually use the Mac app for
PG admin,
but that still just opens the browser as
well. So it's not like a separate UI,
but it should be the same thing regardless.
Okay. Well, we got a comment from Ryan
who says the issue is single threaded in
a single transaction. So using the parallel copy
is significantly faster because the copy is single
threaded.
Yeah. Maybe let's try the parallel copy.
That's the command. That's I think it's the
next command in the doc. Shout out to
Ryan
for his help.
Do I need to install something locally for
this to work? Because I'm not gonna have
Timescale DB parallel copy. Right? Yeah. So if
you just go to the
go back to the tutorial and there's a
link to parallel copy
just above
yeah. Right there.
And there should be some installation instructions as
well.
Yeah. I think it just wants me to
compile it with Go.
Alright.
I'm pretty confident this will be fast.
Once we have that, we are going to
run.
So we need to drop in the connection
string of the DB.
Okay. Let's grab all that just now.
K. That looks better.
Okay. So our connection string and our DB
name. So our DB name is T s
t b.
Yep.
And our connection string, is that gonna be
that fill
forge
thing? That'll just be the
the service you are at the end.
Alright.
And
we need
the link to our file,
Oh, it says download MIC
data CSV.
Right.
CSV.
Password authentication failed. So I think what you
might do is
Flash the password. Right? Yeah. That that's honestly
the hackiest way.
Not good security
practices. Don't don't do what we're doing.
Yeah. Please, nobody break my instance until after
the stream. Afterwards, knock yourself out.
Okay. So do we get any output from
this, or are we just gonna be waiting
for
oh, up every thirty seconds, we're gonna get
some progress at the Yeah. Okay. So we
can wait thirty seconds.
So why don't we discuss some of the
feature sets that Timescale
brings to us? So we've kinda mentioned that
we create hyper tables from our normal tables,
and that brings in all of the time
series functionality.
We kinda spoke about time to live, which
was that, you said, through user defined actions,
which allows you to downsample that data. And
it's
So there's
so on the on the topic of, you
know, how long you wanna retain your data
for, time to live of of your data,
there's a couple of features there. There's one
that is
part of the the data management features, which
is called
setting automated retention policies.
So that's the the name in the docs
that folks can search for.
But the thing that I was mentioning is
that these retention policies are set on a
per hyper table basis, meaning that for every
hyper table you have, you can set different
retention policies for them.
But if you would like to have one
retention policy that applies to, like, all your
hyper tables, you can use
a feature called user defined actions, which is
basically
so we have this
background
scheduler
and things that that we've created in order
to enable stuff like the retention policies to
happen. So what that does is allows you
as a user to take advantage of the
scheduler and that basically, that stuff that's going
on in the back end
to run your own jobs on a on
a specific schedule, and one of them can
be this
down sampling or this compression job or this
data
discarding job as well.
Okay. I mean, and time sampling's important with
time series data. Right? Like, it's probably one
of the first tasks that people should be
doing when they start to store time series
data because
unlike
traditional data that we store and relational or
no SQL stores is that time series data
isn't valuable forever. Is it? Like
Yeah. It depends. Because I think a lot
of the time when you think about the
two major
kinda uses that people have for it, there's
kinda the real time monitoring,
which is
more,
you know, the recent data days is what
you're interested in.
But there's also a case where you wanna
look at historical analysis or just analytics of
how
something has been doing. And there, you know,
the recent data isn't quite important,
but I think you're you're right that and
so for the analysis, it's definitely more you
know, the the more data you have depending
on how long you wanna go back, the
better.
But I definitely
agree that, you know, after a certain amount
of time,
data usefulness does
degrade.
But I think also,
you know, the way it's going today, people
wanna keep data around for an increasing amount
of time because they're doing all sorts of
analysis on it, machine learning models,
you know, all those kinds of things. And
so there's actually a feature that Timescale does
have that allows you to do that,
which is native compression.
Then that's just to keep your your data
storage costs and the actual size on disk
lower than
if it's uncompressed. So traditionally with Postgres,
one of the disadvantages
is that the table sizes used to be
quite big.
But and especially with time series data, you
know, you're inserting data every
you know, whatever your insert period is, it
can pile up quite quickly. So compression does
help to keep that
down and within costs if you're using like
a hosted or if you're even if you're
running a self managed on something like AWS
or something like that.
Cool. Thank you.
So Jared says evening. Hey, Jared. Morning depending
on where you are. What time is it
for you, how far? It's just past my
day. It's like one 1PM now.
Good day to everyone.
And is saying, what about data archival?
I mean, I can try and and fair
what I think you mean there, but please
feel free to just follow-up with a little
bit more detail.
So when we talk about downsampling with time
series, let's use, like, a real time monitoring
as an example. Like, there's something, you know,
if you're collecting
data at
what what would you say is standard for
a Timescale customer? Ten seconds, thirty seconds, one
minute? What what do you see in the
field? Honestly, it really depends on, like, the
use case. So for example, if you're monitoring
machines or say, for example, it's a classic,
like, DevOps use case where you're monitoring
a bunch of servers that you have, then
it's probably gonna be on the second or
millisecond basis.
But if you're
another use case is like
monitoring like weather or
air quality,
then you're probably gonna be looking at it
on like a minute basis because, you know,
the weather doesn't really change that much within
a second or so. So it really just
depends on on your use case.
But, yeah, I think along the the the
the
lines of like a second or a minute
is is usually
to what people use. And then for machines,
if you're getting device data, it'll be at
a much higher fidelity than that, like, millisecond.
Is fidelity the timescale term? I would probably
call it resolution. Are those interchangeable,
or is there any different characteristics to of
timescales?
Oh, no. It's just it's just my
what that I use. Yeah. There's no standard
definition.
We would probably use the word granularity.
Just like how granular you want your data.
You know, if you're gonna downsample that makes
it
less
granular,
whereas if you don't, you're gonna have the
the little grains. I in another presentation, I
have this thing where you have like mountains
of sand. And then when you downsample it,
it becomes like a big rock or like
chunked together. So, yeah, that's something a good
way to visualize it. So maybe we can
try and explain,
you know, going back to Vignesh's question about
data archival. I mean, data archival probably isn't
something that most people would do with Timescale
data, but we we would downsample it and
reduce that resolution or granularity
over time multiple times. So maybe we could
kinda give a traditional workflow there.
Exactly. What I can do is I actually
have a slide on this if I can
share my screen. Oh, yeah. Go for it.
Yeah. Let's do it. Yeah.
Okay. Give me a second.
There you go. Okay.
So
yeah. Basically, like, just to talk you through
with the with the visual here.
I'm not sure why this is taking so
long to go into presentation mode.
Everything seems to be going wrong. Going live.
Yeah. It's like Murphy's Law.
K. Well, let's wait and see. Otherwise, I'll
just
exit.
Okay. Whatever. Let me just exit.
But I think maybe I can
zoom in
a little bit. No. Okay.
Zoom out, it actually works. Okay. But in
this picture,
you can see basically, like, the bottom part
of it is the raw data. And so
raw data, you have a lot of these
little data points coming in.
And then what you would wanna do is
you'd wanna use your raw data for certain
things. You'd only keep it around for a
a certain amount of time.
And then for kind of historical analysis so
say for example, you have like a server
and this server, you're monitoring like the CPU
usage on the server.
And
you'd wanna keep that raw data around for,
like, real time monitoring purposes. But then after,
like, a day or so or after, like,
a week or so, you'd no longer need
to have, you know, millisecond level data about,
like, what was going on on the server.
So then what you would then do is
use
you you basically aggregate that data
to say, okay. Instead of keeping
everything on a millisecond level, just give me
things in five minute intervals. So showing me,
like, every five minutes how my different metrics
that I'm monitoring are changing.
And so you'd use a feature called continuous
aggregates for this that Timescale has. So this
basically takes the raw data and says, okay,
we're gonna just calculate the five minute average
in our case. But you could use any
function you want. So you instead of taking
the average over five minutes, you can take
the maximum.
You can take some sort of calculation,
whatever
method or, like, function you wanna aggregate on,
you can you can do that. And then
what often what people do is keep the
aggregated data around,
but discard the actual raw data. So in
this case, you can see the trash can
with the with the yellow is basically saying,
After a certain amount of time, we're actually
gonna get rid of this raw data, but
the aggregated data still stays around.
And then you can use that for reference
or but it's you can see it's at
a higher
it's at a lower fidelity
or lower resolution
as as you would say, David, whereas this
one is at a higher resolution because it's
just more data points.
And then on the on the topic of
data archival, you can then take this to
say if we, like, go further
move further in time, you can actually use
your own
data storage so that you can put stuff
in like cold storage and stuff like that.
It just depends on your your workflow and
like what kind of data pipeline you wanna
set up. But I know they are
they are capabilities
such that, you know, every
you can set a procedure
to run,
I don't know, every six months or so
or something like that that says, okay. Data
that's older than a certain amount of time,
put it in my cold storage where I
don't actually need to keep it on the
database anymore.
And, you know, have that cycle such that
it goes from
raw data to downsample data at the aggregate
level.
And then after a certain amount of time,
discarding even the downsample data if you want,
that's some option as well.
Awesome. Yeah. Yeah. Great explanation there. So while
you were kind of chatting through that, I
ran the numbers on our file.
So we have a transfer rate of around
15,000 rows per second,
which is gonna take roughly twelve minutes for
the file that we're on, and we're currently
just at eleven minutes. So we're almost there.
Almost there. Okay. Well, hopefully, the the rest
of it can be quick. But it's also
assuming that my very crude math is is
correct. But I think I think we'll be
close for within a minute, probably.
Awesome.
So I guess, let's assume I'm
even if I'm not right that now thereabouts,
we're see what we're gonna be doing with
this data.
So we're just going to do a very
simple select from our rates table, limited to
five. I guess we're just expecting to see
a few a few rows come back. Like,
that's Yeah. That's just to check that the
import worked similar to what you were doing
earlier with the count.
Okay. We'll see some data like so.
And then
we're gonna start doing some analysis in this
data.
So this query wants to take a look
at how many rates took place on each
day for the dataset that we have.
So this is just an a date trunk
as day with account and then grouping by.
So pretty
standard relational
query or even a time series query, I
guess. Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. It's just about, you know, for a
certain day, you wanna look at what happened.
So that's just an intro query.
Moment of truth time. We're at twelve minutes.
I don't wanna see a 12:30.
Wanted to finish.
Same. Yeah. Same. Yeah.
In fact, we can see here that the
total number of rows inserted were about 1,000,000,
and my account that I did was
1.09.
Yeah.
Yeah. I never saw 12 start ace in
my mouth. It was good. I'm happy.
Awesome. Okay. So that worked. So we know
how. For those of you who are at
home, definitely use the parallel copy if you
are short on time or doing a live
stream like we are. Well, yeah. There's a
good point. Right? Because if we'd stuck with
a single threaded copy, we run four workers
there. So that would have taken forty eight
minutes.
Just crazy. I think maybe I just have
a really fast computer because what I usually
do when I insert this is I
just use like p g admin and it
inserts and then I just go make a
cup of tea and it's done. So I
don't know. Maybe it's just like the the
Mac that I'm using. But I wonder if
PG and then does the parallelism
too for you. Who knows? That might be
something to investigate. I'm not sure.
Alright. Now now I'm getting a bit more
confident. So
yeah. That's definitely gonna give me a big
number. Okay.
Any second. So let's grab our limit.
That should be nice and quick.
Yeah. So this is our check. Make sure
we got the thing.
Regretting that count now.
Yeah.
There we go. Well, this is also because
I think we're using, like, the very smallest
instance. So
Yeah. We did pick the smallest instance. But
even then, it should be enough to do
this tutorial. So We'll be fine. Something to
talk to my team about.
Alright. So let's try our first time series
query. So this is
gripping assistant account on a window. The window
is per day. Right? Yeah. So this is
just a query that, you know, to give
people a taste of what sorts of questions
you might ask when you're doing
time series analysis or time series based analysis
on something. So the way the tutorial is
broken up is the first part is historical
analysis,
and the second part is more like real
time monitoring.
Okay. So this is what you've
So I'm gonna go slightly
off script now. Go for it. Curious.
So we've done a select
as the
current
group.
Now Yeah. Does does that mean I could
do
hour
as hour? And let's limit this so it's
not gonna be too long. So from where
pickup date time is greater than or equal
to
and
pickup.
I it can just be one.
Okay. Yeah. Less than or equal to yeah.
That's fine. That's fine. Let's just do a
year. Right? So I want Aniston as
oh, no. So the thing about this dataset
is that
it's data from, I think, 2017
or so.
So we'll just have to use that that
time. Well, I I can just give you
just put in,
yeah, January 1 and, like, January 8.
Because the thirty one days is, like, the
full month of the rides.
So
And let's just do three days. Three days.
Yeah. Three days. And five hour. Because that's
that's to me would be
an another standard time to do. You know,
when I have this kind of
an aggregated data, I wanna be able to
see how many rides are were in a
day or how many sales I had in
a day. Then I may want I may
want to break that down by the hour
and say, okay. Well, which hours am I
selling the most?
So I have no idea whether my date
trunk hour is gonna work, but I'm gonna
assume okay. We still got the account from
rides.
Now that that the three day when three
day period and an hourly window. Oh, I
broke it.
So what did I get wrong here?
I just made up that where syntax.
Is that wrong?
Do I need the time?
It shouldn't really
need the time.
I think maybe
the double quotes
That what it is. Okay. Might be the
issue.
I have a
reference query that I can check out as
well. Alright. This is what I get for
going off script and It's all good.
But if I went to the Yeah. It's
definitely the the it's use single quotes for
the date. Okay. And
it's the month first before the day. So,
again, American
data
standards, unfortunately, for
you know, I'm from South Africa, I'm still
not used to people in America, like, with
their own
ways of of notating things. So
yeah.
So it'll be o one can't be right.
Surely, this is ISO standard though. Right? This
is ISO eight six zero one. So the
I I just can't see how
that would be right. It has to be
a three here.
Yeah. So three there and then
yeah. That's correct. Yeah.
Yeah. So that would There we go. So
we can see
clearly this is people leaving clubs.
Yeah. On New Year's Eve, twenty five thousand,
thirty thousand
taxis. It kinda dies down at 5AM,
and then normality seems to kick in eleven
the next day or at least leave the
larger numbers.
Awesome.
Nice.
Cool.
So
thank you Stack Overflow once again.
So now the tutorial is walking us through
and it's asking us, yeah, what was the
average fare then for these passengers?
So this is a select
by day
run an average function on the fare amount
where passenger count was one.
Oh, okay. So you have quite a lot
of data in the sample dataset then. But
even though so many passengers were in each
of the Yeah. So it's actually the reason
why we selected this. So just a good
example of, the kind of things that you'd
wanna track. Like, as much as you also
you wanna know, like, when the rides took
place and how many, you also wanna know
all sorts of, like, metadata associated with. So
it's a good example of, like, why where
you would need
both time series and metadata together to ask,
like, real world questions that that people generally
ask about.
Okay. So we can see that the average
fare for a
New York City cab with one person is
around 11 to $12.
Per per day. Yeah. So
Oh, that's why I changed the number for
the sake of it there. Right. Let's go.
So
now we can see our results. We can
also do
rate types.
Let's see what this looks like. This one,
if you just scroll down a bit on
the tutorial, there's like a
enriched version of that that query
that is actually the next one.
Yeah. So if you just do that one,
that one actually might be better. It it
calculates the same thing, but
gives us a little bit more to talk
about.
Okay. So this is then
select from the rates description. So one of
our metadata non time series tables. Yeah.
Count vendor as number of trips.
What's the rank function? I'm not familiar with
that one. So that's just to rank the
output.
So we wanna have
we're ranking the output by the number of
trips that took place.
There might be a lot of advance for
some people. But, yeah, that's just
you I I'm not sure if it's
a %
necessary,
but I think it's just to make it
quicker.
Okay. Well, it's definitely two times for me
so we can gloss over it. We then
joining our metadata web, the time series data,
and then just providing on here. So we're
just saying Exactly. Match on the rate of
the case. So that's the sorry. On your
go. No. I was gonna say that's just
a big thing that to take away from
this query. So you can see, like, the
original question is, like, how many rides took
place for each
type of ride. So you can imagine, like,
in any other case, wanna segment your
measurements by something. So in this case, we're
using, like, the the the type of ride,
like, the fare type. So you can see,
like, rides that are
grouped or going to a certain airport in
New York City. JFK is one of the
airports.
And that's just a simple example of how
you can join time series and
relational data together in one query,
which is again a a unique thing that's
enabled by Timescale by keeping both of them
on the same database.
Awesome.
Okay. So we're now gonna oh, we're getting
a big one now. So let's actually see
what this is doing. This one is gonna
analyze the rates to JFK,
I'm not familiar with my New York airport
codes. Yeah. It's just another airport called Newark
International Airport. Yeah. It's there in the disc
in the text.
Alright.
Okay. Let's run the query and see.
Yeah. So this is an example of, like,
a question that you might wanna know. So
for any two
types
of
things that you're monitoring, you wanna just do
a quick comparison and, you know, see how
how they compare to each other. This is
an example of that just using rides to
an airport
as as example.
Alright. So compared in those, we can see
the number of trips, the average duration,
forty five versus thirty five minutes. We can
see
the average of the cost, the average of
the tip.
Weird that the forty five minute trip to
JFK has an average tip of $7, but
this thirty five minute drive has an average
tip of nearly 10.
That's weird as well. Also, the total is
a lot higher
for the the the shorter airport, the Newark
Airport.
Oh, yes. So it is. Yeah. So we
actually if I don't wanna keep saying go
back to the tutorial, but basically, this is
this is an example of, like, you know,
people keep talking about, you know, you wanna
do data driven analysis and,
you know, have this kind of insight into,
like, what's going on. So this is an
example of, like, an ad hoc query that
someone might wanna do on your time series
data, but then combining it to the relational
data and saying, like, okay. What's interesting in
this dataset that we can talk about? And
as you've just said, you know, there's some
interesting things we can get from here. Like,
even though the trip is shorter,
the
the total is much higher. And even though
the trip was was
longer for the other airport, the tip is
much lower. And so, like, there's also the
interesting things that you can get
from Timescale's data.
Alright. Yeah. Very cool.
Let's see what else does it got. So
mission three is is monitoring.
So this is we our question is how
many regs took place every five minutes for
the first day of 2016?
So this is very similar to the query
that you did
kind of off the script earlier,
which is
yeah. So so this is just using
vanilla Postgres.
What is it?
Notation or
syntax is the correct word. So that's how
you would do it using the date trunk
function.
But the next query is gonna illustrate one
of the
time series specific functions that Timescale has, which
is called time bucket,
which basically allows you to
more easily
select, like, what kind of
time periods you wanna analyze your data in.
So,
like, for example, you know, using day trunk
earlier, we saw that it was easy to
analyze things in time periods of, like, an
hour or a day. But what if your
main unit in your business is, like, fifty
minutes or,
like, six minutes or ten seconds or something
some, you know, nonstandard thing?
This is a function that we've developed time
bucket to to help make that really easy
because this is the kind of question that's
often asked in in time series use cases.
Yeah. That's really cool. So it's just a
convenience function that allows you to do window
and work on my simpler syntax without worrying
about trunking the dates and and things like
that. That's nice. And you can just change
it, you know, from if you don't wanna
look at five minutes, you wanna look at,
like, forty five minutes or something like that.
It's a one line change whereas
with the day trunk function, the math, you're
gonna have to do a little bit of
maths to make sure that you're right that
you're right. Yeah.
Awesome.
Very handy.
Yeah.
Okay. Our next question is how many rays
on New Year's morning originated within four hundred
miles of Times Square and thirty minute buckets?
Yeah. Okay.
Oh, we need to do something fancy here.
So this is another example of, like, you
know, talking about how timescales based on Postgres.
You can use any other Postgres extension
with Timescale.
And one thing that we often see people
using
is combining time series analysis with geospatial analysis.
So for example, instead of just knowing how
something changes over time, you wanna know how
something changes over time and space. So, you
know, any logistics company or any someone that's
tracking
the movement of their fleet of trucks or
something, this is, like, relevant to them.
And so this is just a a quick
query to show that, you know, if you
wanna actually do geospatial analysis, this is how
you do it with this extension called post
GIS.
K. So we enable the extension,
and then we also have the table to
tell it. Okay. Right. So this is we're
saying that we've got some sort of coordinates
inside of our data and we need to
change the column type over.
And I'm assuming
oh, we just got a quick update. Yeah.
This is just allowing the the,
what is it, the location data that we
have and converting it to, like, standard coordinates
so that,
you know, the queries will work. There's an
example that I can pull up after this
to show you, like, what a
what this would look like on, like, a
live dashboard
versus now we're just gonna obviously gonna get
a number in the terminal of, like, the
number of rides.
Yeah. I must have been because we spun
up a quite a small instance, the update
here maybe just take a little. That might
actually be true. Yeah.
So I think this is this is really
nice.
I like that, you know, it's not just
the,
you know, the storage layer, the query plan
and extensions, but it's the providing of helper
functions to help make more traditional times use
queries
simpler for people to kind of type and
and work with,
I guess, on a on a daily basis.
Yeah. The the integration with the post guest
extension, I think, is is very clever. You
know, you're very
anytime she just do it and it has
latitude and longitude information on it, you're you're
gonna wanna be able to map it over
over time and space. And I think being
able to visualize that. I can imagine that
would work really well with your fan hooked
up to it, and you could choose Exactly.
Really cool visualization languages to see. While we
wait, let me actually share the screen to
to show people what this looks like. Yeah.
Go for it.
Let's see. So I'm just I've got a
Grafana dashboard right here. And what's going on
the screen in front of me is I'm
looking at the current locations of buses in
New York City,
and I'm using Timescale as my data source.
So if I just zoom into one of
these
these panels in Grafana, So you can see
here I'm using Timescale,
the Postgres
data source in Grafana.
And I've got a little SQL query here
to just basically
show me the the the location of the
different buses. So you can see I've got
my latitude and longitude,
and I'm just coloring the buses based on
their route. So each there's a different, like,
bus routes that they have. And so you
end up with something like
this panel right here, which shows you, like,
you know, for different buses. This is bus
type m.
It's in this location.
These are bus type b. They're in originally
mostly run-in that location.
So if, you know, you get, like, this
overview of, like, what's going on right now.
And then this is another interesting
example where, you know, you don't just wanna
know the location of
your buses. You also wanna know, like, when
something is wrong. So in this case, let
me actually zoom in a little bit.
The purple buses are the buses that are
actually off their specified route. So what I've
done is
I've specified
some
some,
like, kind of geographic
lines where each bus has their own, like,
line that they need to follow. And wherever
they're off that line, I just have an
is a case statement here in SQL that
says, like, okay, then that means this bus
is on route and off route. You can
imagine
doing this where, you know, if your device
is on, like, low power, if you're monitoring,
like, a bunch of
devices in the field or something like that
or if there's some kind of errant
behavior,
you can actually identify to say, like, okay.
That's where it's happening and everything else is
green. It's okay. And again, this is is
using SQL to do it. So it's quite
a powerful query that's just a few lines
long.
And that's another example of, like, the real
time
aspect of, like, okay, combining time series and
geospatial data.
Very cool. I like that.
So this update query is still running. So
we're also approaching about an hour and twenty
minutes now. So why don't we is there
any more demos that you'd like to show?
Maybe we could finish on that. And then
I know we had a few problems and
there's more content for us to cover, but
maybe we could schedule a a part two
where we do a slightly different live. I
think we need to because the part one
was mostly let's just get everything set up.
So I I wouldn't be opposed to that.
Yeah. Yeah. Let me let me actually share
my screen again and and take you through
some quick
high level
demos.
So
okay. So we're back in Grafana. So on
this keeping on this theme of buses,
you know, David talked about earlier, you know,
you wanna know how your volume is changing
over time. So this is just like buses
on a specific route,
how they
how many buses are on the road at
any particular time. And you can see, you
know, this pattern of during the day, obviously,
the buses are gonna be at the highest
and in the evenings or at after midnight,
everything kinda shuts down. This is just a
very easy way to to detect the patterns
of, like, what's going on. And I'm using
a
function here, the time bucket function,
to look at these in five minute intervals.
I could easily look at these things in
something like sixty eight minute intervals for some
reason.
And I guess I'm running a quite powerful
instance here so that the thing is quick.
So you can actually see and change the
fidelity at which you look at data. The
other thing you can do as well is
if I wanna look at something over, like,
seven days,
that's just, you know, a a quick change.
And there, I can actually see the general
trend is that it's it's trending downward
over the past seven days.
But I'm gonna keep this as five minutes.
Go back to the original one. And then
some other things that are interesting is we
have functions
to deal with common time series
time series problems that happen. So one of
them is a function called
gap fill, which is basically
allows you to fill in gaps in your
data.
So
the comparison here is
let me find a
table that has a gap in it.
Okay. So say in this example here, you
can see at 3AM
on the February 7,
I didn't have any vehicles on the road.
And so it just shows me like a
dash here, meaning like there's no there's no
data.
But we have like two functions that you
can use depending on how you wanna treat
these gaps because often you wanna have like
a continuous line when you're doing some sort
of a time time series analysis.
So one of them is gonna be to
interpolate
between the last two values. So let me
just
find the right time,
And that's gonna be at 3PM.
Three AM, I think. So,
yeah, between two and 3AM.
Okay. Cool. So you can see here
the number here is a one and the
number here is a three, and we have
two gaps in the middle. So if I
use this interpolate function,
the output between the one and the three,
I'm just gonna get the linear interpolation. So
it's gonna assume that, okay, between
one and two
between,
yeah, one and two, it's gonna go from
three to three to two, and then from
two to 1.6, and then all the way
to one. But, of course, since I'm counting
buses, there's no such thing as, like, 2.33
buses that doesn't exist.
So we have another function that you can
use called
LOCF,
which means last object or last observation carried
forward,
which allows you to solve this problem by
just taking the last number
and carrying it forward. So you can see
here
between this time of, like, 1AM and 4AM,
it just assumes that I just had three
buses on the road at that time until
I hit 4PM where my next data point
comes in. And these functions, just to give
you a sense of how they look, they're
just these one
line functions where you're saying
LOCF,
the
the quantity that you want to count,
and then you're using this function called time
bucket gap fill instead of a date trunk
or time bucket
to calculate your time values. So those are
just two other examples of these, like, handy
SQL functions for time series analysis.
And then I just wanna show you one
last thing,
which is
okay. So this is this is a different
dataset. This is actually monitoring live air quality
data in India.
And so you can see here, I've got
a bunch of, like,
air quality metrics,
ozone,
nitrous dioxide.
This is, like, particulate matter over 25 nanometers.
So there's a bunch of metrics. And I've
also got a certain location that I'm monitoring,
which is in Agra, which is a fun
fact where the Taj Mahal is in India.
So they probably wanna know what the air
quality is in there. They got a lot
of tourists. So this is actually quite a
real use case.
And so I've shown you a time bucket
gap film already. There's another function that allows
you just to get the last reading for
each location.
And so if I go to view this
classic live scenario, it's taking long.
But basically, over here, it shows me, like,
for each of these parameters at the place
that I'm looking at, this is the last
reading that I have. And so you can
imagine, like, you wanna know the status, the
last
received
reading from some sort of devices that you're
monitoring,
and you don't know where that when that's
gonna where that's gonna be. And so we
have this function
handy time series function that just shows you
the last value
as ordered by time. So this is different
from just calculating the value and then ordering
by time because sometimes
depending on this has to do with, like,
the the query the way the query planner
executes.
If you use this function, it's a lot
more efficient than scanning the whole database
for to find this this last value. This
actually takes advantage of some of the
chunking and and stuff that I talked about
earlier with the hyper table. So that's a
a an overview of the features of,
like, the handy SQL functions.
And then here,
I've got just got an overview of, like
you know, we talked about earlier about downsampling
and continuous aggregates.
The data that I've that what I'm showing
here is going to be the
daily average.
Again, I'm not sure why this full screen
view is not working. But basically, this shows,
like, the daily average of different
air quality metrics.
And that's an example of, like, okay, we
have data coming in, like, every 15 minutes
or something like that, but we've down sampled
it here to be
every day just to show the
max, minimum, and average. So again, it's example
where you don't just have to down down
sample it to the average, you can take
whatever
function you want, whatever aggregate function. So here
we have both the max, the average, and
the minimum
of all these different metrics
for and that's using Timescale continuous aggregates.
So, yeah, you know, that's just a a
little overview of, like, some of the real
world use cases that you can do. I
like to demonstrate things with Grafana dashboards because,
you know, this is something that
people would look at all the time. It's
also easier than working with the terminal, which
we see has caused us a lot of
problems today. But yeah. This is just an
overview of the sorts of things you can
do at Timescale.
And I've just got a slide later on
just for with some links that people can
go to if they wanna learn more.
But we'll we'll get to that in a
in a few minutes.
Yeah. You're right. Timescale is data is very
visual, and I think Grafana dashboards are a
great way to kinda understand trends and, you
know, peaks and troughs and really just get
a glance at what is happening through the
data. So, yeah, Grafana dashboards and graphing in
general is really important.
%.
Okay. So I think what we'll do is
you and I can catch up after this
episode. We will get something scheduled because I
feel that we've got so much more we
can cover.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Arranged that. And then if
you wanna pull up your slides, we can
give some people some more resources to take
a look at. And then I will let
you get back to your day, and I
will speak to you again soon. Yeah. No.
For sure. I I think that there's definitely
some
interest in folks wanting to learn about, you
know, how would, like, a data life cycle
look like from raw data to downsample to
discard it. So maybe that's actually a topic
that we could do.
But in the meantime, for folks who
enjoyed what we saw today and who wanna
get started with Timescale,
the best place is to do so in
the docs, docs.timescale.com.
We also have a newsletter that sends out
any feature updates or any tutorials
and stuff that we have, learning material. So
you can just go to the short link
tstb.co/timescale-
newsletter.
If you wanna get help using Timescale,
we have a community of thousands of users
in our developer Slack as well as folks
like myself,
Timescale CTO,
Mike Friedman,
Ryan, who helped out on this livestream. He's
actually a developer advocate at Timescale.
And so you can find us all in
the Timescale Slack
where we can give you help, you know,
if you're trying to figure out if Timescale
fits your needs or if you can't quite
get something to work. Folks are there to
help you.
And then at the end
oh, and then and then if you wanted
to use Timescale, the easiest way to get
started is with the hosted database.
You can start a free trial at tstb.co/getstartedcloud.
That's actually quite a long short link. But,
yeah, hit that up.
Might have to change that one. But, yeah,
there's there's so many things there. And then
my name is at aftar in Slack. So
you can just find me and at me,
and I'll be happy to help you personally.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Alright. That was
we had a few challenges, but we showed
off some really cool features of Timescale. We'll
get something started to show off even more
of that. We'll tackle data. You know? I
I think we can really dig in to
the data sampling data over time and show
people how that works and how to work
within that. Lots of great content to come.
Tara, thank you very much for joining me
today.
I will speak to you again soon. Have
a great day. Thank you, David, and thanks
everyone who watched and who's gonna watch the
recording.
Please use Timescale.
Awesome. Alright. I'll see you soon. Thank you.
Bye bye.